- Another thing I wanted to say is
you actually had a residency
at Planet Hollywood, right?
And I'm about to have one, so,
did you love it?
- You're gonna love it.
- Okay, I'm a little nervous just 'cause
it's so dry in Vegas.
- No, no, no, no, no,
forget about anything you've
ever heard about that,
the stereotype of that.
The beauty of it is you play the show
and you go home at night.
- Yeah, and the same place.
- And it's the same, listen,
you have to understand,
when we do a world tour,
it's literally fly, play, fly, play,
occasionally you'll sleep.
Planet Hollywood's gonna
be so great for you
because the crowd is adorable.
Number one, anything you say or do,
they're gonna, and you're a talker.
- Yeah, ah, what? (laughing)
(crowd laughing)
You don't say?
- So, you have to understand
what makes it so wonderful is
we talk to them, we don't just sing,
we interact with them--
- That's part of the--
- They're part of the show.
- Yeah, 'cause if you
just wanted the music, you
could just close your eyes
and imagine the show and
listen to the record.
- You are going to love it,
you are going to love it.
- I'm excited.
- Yeah.